das habe ich jetzt nicht unbedingt
geplant
also da haben wir noch ein bisschen zeit
nein kann ich mir schon vorstellen
[Musik]
willkommen bei unserem neuen video ich
mache ist immer die animation bei
unseren videos und herzlich willkommen
zu unserem neuen video
ja ich mache jetzt immer die
anmoderation bei uns ja okay jetzt ganz
aber schon lange wieder gehen vielleicht
aber ich hoffe natürlich geht es gut er
heute ist marie wieder dabei meine
freundin wir haben heute was ganz
spezielles vor juli ist denn da der
kamera juli hat acht fragen ausgesucht
acht sehr sehr interessante fragen sehr
sehr spannende fragen die wir getrennt
beantworten
das ganze habe ich nicht gefunden das
gibt schon sind bei ganz vielen youtube
an deswegen würde ich gar nicht sagen
was als erstes erfunden hat ein freund
von mir mag der macht das ja sehr oft
schöne grüße celina auch schöne grüße
noch jemanden abstand auf in brüssel
das war es dann auch schon genau und ich
habe schon gehört marie muss anfangen
deswegen darfst du auf diesem stuhl
ach so und ich habe einen krassen kummer
ich hab ein krasses feature überlegt
wenn ich hier sitze ist das glauben
männlich ist schlecht und wenn maria
singt ach so vergessen zu sagen ich gehe
natürlich ein traum das heißt ich
bekomme davon nichts mit sondern erst
wenn ich dann das video fertig sehe
ich würde echt schön und reich klaffe
eine so jetzt haben wir aufgestellt
jetzt bin ich dran und hat die gute
träume hat die gut beantworten wer hat
da ich gewesen bin ich definitiv solche
kern kommt bisher nicht ich selbst wenn
er erklärt bisschen dazu ja wenn ich
sage dass irgendwie also ich kann mich
schon durchsetzen wenn sie ja
wahrscheinlich gesagt sie ihn extra so
als hätte er die hosen an wenn ich zum
beispiel sagen kannst du mich da an der
abfahrt hat mich da an leistung bringen
sagt thema erst nein und dann kriege ich
dir jedes mal dazu also wirklich jedes
mal also theoretisch also eigentlich
ganz kategorien hat sie gesagt bedeutet
nicht weißt du nicht siehst du im video
also wenn ich wirklich also die wenn ich
mich dann zum beispiel wenn sie dann
irgendwie will der wildauer ist weißt du
und ich das dann so also die kommt immer
wieder an das ding also ich kann
eigentlich also ich mache jetzt nichts
schlimmes oder so aber ich kann schon
entscheidend wie was gemacht wird kann
man ja auch nicht immer so und manchmal
ist das auch okay so dass ich sie das
konzert zu unterdrücken
das ist aber okay manchmal auch sie
beide so ein bisschen okay okay
[Musik]
er ist ein gestoppter
allerdings zeigen die erzählen mir immer
alles wenn sie irgendwas geplant hat was
passiert wie jetzt der tag verläuft zum
beispiel wenn die morgens frühstück
danach lernt dann mittag ist dann sich
mit ihrer freundin trifft und abends
germany's next topmodel guckt erzählt
die mail kurz was du gemacht dass diese
stimmungsschwankungen hat dessen
richtiges mädchen also an manchen tankt
sich gut drauf oder eigentlich das
schwankt sogar innerhalb von stunden
damit das wunder kommt auch so
irgendwann mit haus kommt dann so ok das
habe ich jetzt schon noch dass er jetzt
schon jetzt mach ich das noch das mache
ich jetzt dann mache ich das noch nicht
denken wir ja mach einfach
also es ist ja auch nett was man dass er
sagt aber manchmal erzählt sie auch ein
bisschen zu sehr auf masse grad macht
oder was sie gerade vor hat
[Musik]
wer jetzt lustig wenn wir das gleiche
sagen ja aber du kannst du erzählen
ja ich weiß wo ich überlegt wird also
ich fand erst unsere kennenlernen
geschichte die haben mir letztens in
einem video erzählt bin ich schon
ziemlich lustig weil das alles irgendwie
so aufzufallen passiert habt also das
muss ich schon sagen ist schon einer der
krassesten zumindest hat die direkt aus
gefunden
wie war noch mal die frage lustiger
moment oder lustige story die euch
während eure beziehung passiert das gab
es doch viele lustige mainzer so exakt 1
weiß ich noch nicht
kannst du nichts wurde jetzt so einfach
war das so behindert lustig oder so
eigentlich jeden tag als ich das erste
mal mit marie in urlaub gefahren bin
da kann ich sie noch nicht so lange da
sind wir nach hamburg zum flughafen
gefahren und ich wurde auf dem weg dahin
drei mal geblitzt
es ist so schön lustig so die dachte
doch wahrscheinlich erst der junge hat
so ganz am anfang ja du bist einfach mit
der wusste dreimal geflext okay was hat
sie gesagt ich auf jeden fall das ist
ich kann mir also also die räume nie was
weg in mein zimmer da sieht es aus wenn
ihr das zimmer verlässt wie im social
kaffeetassen muss ich noch waschen
irgendwelche wetter fliegen durch die
gegend bestens nicht gemacht hat macht
alles ich irgendwie hier komme ich ja
mal davor ist ja irgendwie rollentausch
alle findest du in dein konto nicht dass
marias immer das blatt macht oder auch
eben ich habe auch wieder gekocht so und
ich koche eigentlich immer die koki also
alexis definitiv ordentlich vereinen
jetzt gerade meine klausurphase musste
mir alles hinterher räumen
aber ich hoffe dass ich irgendwann ist
es ist ja okay es sollen beide kochen
meiste aber ich komme schon öfter muss
ich sagen kann ich mir schon vorstellen
wobei glaube ich nicht für immer
da ich jetzt nicht so bock drauf weil
man hier natürlich auch die ganzen
freunde hat und so aber wenn dann so na
ja schon was ich ganz cool fand bis zu
spanien oder so irgendwann mal oder usa
aber ich war ja ein neues anderes leben
kann ich das jetzt nicht genau sagen
aber kommt ja das ding ist im winter ist
sagt auftakt sobald aber so in spanien
und können dinge vorstellen
der kommentar bei endeavour dann vor
kurzem das ist meine freunde sympathisch
man kann sie unter maria recht nette
freundin so die ich auch - also gar
nicht was alles liebe alex frei
juli dich ganz doll lieb aber auch seine
freundin zu hören ich nehme mir wirklich
alle
also hat echt tolle freunde in hübsche
freundin sympathische nette freundin mit
dem man auch feststellen kann man so wie
ich bin
die sind alle pool mit dem viele und
schießen sie nicht vernichten soll den
mann aus china aktiv und zählt heute
sagen manche waren fehlen sie hatten
eine freundin mit dem man aufbauen kann
so dass man zu erstellen
eine heimat zu geben wir angewohnheit
oder wird du kriegst sofern sie ja
eigentlich so ja da passt das ja wieder
mit dem was sie mir immer genau erzählt
was sie jetzt in den nächsten fünf
minuten beziehungsweise im verlauf des
tages macht sie an tig ansonsten das
also was echten katic bei ihm das ist
dass sein bett immer ordentlich also ich
mich halt manchmal auch seinen weg weil
sein spiegel dahinter ist zum beispiel
wenn dann irgendwie auch nur ein ganz
ganz kleines stückchen puder oder sonst
was drauf fällt oder wenn ich zwischen
mit kuli ausprobieren dann kaufe ich
werde nicht fit lernen das wird sich
richtig aus und sagt du kannst bei
meinem bett nicht umgehen also das
einparken geht nicht muss immer jemand
gucken ob da irgendwo was passieren
könnte das rückwärtseinparken was ich
immer dazu kommen und zu sagen jetzt
schon richtig dass jetzt schon
funktionieren mag einfach es schwierig
einfach nett
[Musik]
brown bleibt sollte ich mir ehrlich
sagen meinte sie 1000 grün blau so eine
mischung also ich kenne jetzt history
erzählt ist wieder gefragt aber alex
frei ist meine arbeit ist okay aber nun
schnelligkeit sowie ist so richtig ja
keine ahnung küsst dann schleunigst raus
nein das ist schon richtig
[Musik]
hey nein das habe ich jetzt nicht
unbedingt geplant
also da haben wir noch ein bisschen zeit
also können wir stolz sein
und gestern haben wir bei den kämpfen
ich habe schon gesagt bestätigt besetzt
werden also in den nächsten 2 watt aber
das wäre dann schon 2020 also bis zum 16
verloren sondern 2022 sowie meint ihr
fernseh antrag gesehen ich habe gesagt
wenn du so etwas jemals machst oder in
einem gp dann sage ich ihm half also da
bin ich ja dann also da bin ich mal noch
viel zu jung
also ich könnte mir vorstellen so wird
die hat ja auch nein gesagt safe oder
ich könnte mir vorstellen so bis 2028
irgendwann da vielleicht aber davor
nein danke auch wenn ich raus aber gut
ist ja auch glaube ich also ich finde
das auch castro leute die mit 20
heiraten ireland schaden oder ich kenne
jemanden von der kennt jemand der mit 19
geheiratet und seine fracht sind diese
zwei jahre zusammen geblieben
okay okay das war es musste wieder zum
standesamt ganzen papiere also nicht
dass das bei mir jetzt passiert aber ich
glaube das ist dann die gefahr wenn man
so viel zu früh geheiratet weil man
einfach noch zu jung ist ein muss im
ausland
okay dass ich dann drin waren es alle
daran dass man alles gleich ich hoffe ja
den spaß lasse nach oben da abonniert
marien salam und mich auch und juli auf
und ja das war rein
[Musik]